ja ich habe schon einige tönis barcelona
nein das kenne ich meine lieben freunde
und herzlich willkommen zurück zu
minecraft cap tiff zwei verbindung zum
server der service immer noch mal auf
beuge ich dass die aufnahme ist einfach
weiterlaufen wir haben in der letzten
folge krass viele sachen getan wir sind
gestorben
wir haben die hölle falsch erkundet wir
haben ganz viele places gefunden ich
wäre fast nie lava gefallen alles
möglich wieder krasse sachen ich hoffe
wir können wenn ich auf dem server für
unsere items liegen noch in der hölle
und der service immer noch im aufbau
natürlich auch dabei jetzt einfach
wieder ewigkeiten in harrow minecraft
freunde schreibt dass man die kommentare
während das für wieder aufbauen ist
anmelden welt jetzt geht's jetzt schnell
altern wollen aber im juli besser ich
auch die letzte folge unseres four
produzieren zu wollen falls zu probieren
wir müssen erstmal die ganzen 100 dann
würde ich sagen erst mal wieder raus und
die sachen kurz sortieren nicht dass ein
auf einmal 4 fährt das schwert hat und
der andere fackeln oder so
wegen der lohne routine die könnten wir
später noch gebrauchen eventuell ja
wegen dem zauberte den kann man auch
machen so meine items linie schon bei
meiner liegen hier ich bin ein bisschen
weiter abseits
er sammelt einfach meine eltern sein
nein das guck dir ohne lohn route liegt
ja wo wir doch der erfolg ja aber coco
sie liegt ganz einsam und alleine wir
brauchen eine laser ok haben wir alles
mitgenommen haben wir alles mit wir
haben alles dabei
von i ja ich habe schon einige töne
barcelona nein ist das skelett alter wo
das hat mich immer wieder wie in faro
getötet terrors du hast alle sachen ja
ich bin okay du hast wahrscheinlich
relativ viel ich habe relativ wenig aber
ich hab zwei routen ok wieder nachts
schnell nach unten können
aber warum kennen wir haben wir waren
schon mal ach ja stimmt ja klar denn ich
bin wegen zucker ausgemacht ich ja
endlich stimmt denn wir schlafen gehen
dann wächst das auch schneller
wahrscheinlich oder ich weiß es nicht
vielleicht kann ich mir gut vorstellen
kommt jetzt die schlacht liegt drin
walter mein ganzer nacken beim mittel
alles kannst mir erst mal ein paar
sachen geht da sind deine sachen sie
liegen alle da aber ein schwert ist weg
hab ich komme ja aus neustadt das archiv
mit wenn man sich im vorstand macht egal
wer jetzt im raum stand enke die tränke
die tränke wird wir haben sogar tränke
mach du das einfach so haben wir die
glasflaschen waren und jetzt
machen wir so jetzt ist er dabei jetzt
weiter wir von damals kannst du eben
warte hast du noch irgendwas von mir du
musst es noch einen links von mir haben
etwas bogen pfeile da noch eine axt
fackeln sonst noch was
nunmehr habe ich nicht komme ja guck mal
was hier vor steht komme hierhin in
diesem raum
ja oh mein gott auf wir haben aber auf
deck hatte sowie nicht verwandten besitz
gefunden das hab ich mir gedacht dafür
brauchen wir noch viel mehr diamanten
aber na gut die karte geht auch noch
weiter runter wir waren ja noch gar
nicht ganz unten auf bedburg höhe stimmt
jetzt haben aber wieder diese scheiß
dickflüssigen tränke die zum nächsten
nützlich sind wir wären ja eh nicht
verzögern sondern packe ich erst mal die
andere kiste wieder wenn er relativ
wertlos eigentlich in der komplett
wertlos eigentlich ja so da kann man
aber rein bruchsteine sie müssen ja
wenig aufkommen dass wenn wir beim
lachen nachdem vorproduzieren wieder
aufnehmen hirano in saubere bude kommen
vielleicht könnte man auch mal wir sind
ja voll produzieren und jetzt ist
nämlich der moment gekommen dass wir
noch mitten in kempten zwei sind aber
wir sind gar schon die folgen
vorproduzieren die einen tag nach meinem
urlaub kommt also dann werden wir alle
folgen hier nachkommen sind auf jeden
fall frisch aufgenommen und dann hätte
ich die welt noch mal vielleicht bock
daran ein livestream zu machen wo wir
das ganze schöne bauen
naja jetzt hast du dir dann machst und
ich weiß da nur darauf hinweisen wenn
man internet läuft das nicht aber zum
beispiel das ganze mal genauso wie du
das machst ein bisschen schöner bauen
überall so ein paar sachen alte künftig
gerne wochen darauf hätte ich auch mega
flop weil unserem live stream das wär
super dann können die leute sagen ok ich
hab keinen bock das anzuschauen
die müssen es nicht anschauen und was
alles gefällt einfach runter was mal
unsere wunderschöne tür ob ich die ihn
reingelegt die tür ist weg ich habe sie
wieder die alte gute tür
die einen hier altach die tür
die meinst du nicht klingt eine die tür
ich würde sagen wenn ich irgend eine tür
weil da sie macht das jetzt auch schon
so schön weil ich das toll fand soll
jeder bekommen die hühner vielleicht
soll das tolle ist noch eben hier dann
gibt's trotzdem mal weg na ja stimmen
müssen wir noch ein bisschen was machen
sie platz oder so was kommt ihren wir
müssen auch mal pink kommt dahin alte
hat durch das achievement ist oben oben
die truhe frei geworden oh yeah so bitte
laster 36 diamanten drin sein
ja man muss wieder gewachsen dass mir
der nacht bringt nicht viel was machst
du was schön hier mit dem hochbau das
einer gar nicht gierig eine lehre karte
2 ps3 gold nagels und kürbiskerne
braucht man vielleicht kürbisse für
orange farbe ich bin verteilen die roma
brauchen wir nicht aber hey und guck mal
da sind willi betz und mit blumen noch
erde und die blumen und liegen damit um
oder und wollen die export- und erde
genau klar die kommandantur klangfülle
der clownfisch mit plünderungen 3 und
ganz viele seerosenblätter wir müssen
die gar nicht darum abbauen können hier
ich habe fünf stück ok ich nehme die
blüte mit einfach so die blume habe ich
dann nämlich die ehrliche auch mal mit
aber warum war nach oben aber was machen
wir mit dem blue den clown fisch ist
immer die frage warum ist bestimmt wie
bei will lieber kann herrlich amüsant
clownfisch mit plünderungen 3 3 aus ok
ja er heisst ja auch clownfische
vielleicht deswegen mbh davids von dem
rapper steller er wie bei epic john webb
das mit dem sport.de keiner waren
creepers borner
all diese regeln potato alte die region
passt in unsere essens kiste einfach
gebranntem ton oder ziegel und
vielleicht warst du das ich hab keinen
der artikel du warst das sollte man die
ganzen sachen wir müssen das machen wir
dann alles im leid tun wenn ihr das
wollt könnt ihr unter dieser folge
einfach mal bitte darunter schreiben
wendet durch kurt veränderte solcher
bereichen glaubt damit können wir auch
noch ein paar einer siegchance schön aus
mit dem eichenlaub nur auf jeden fall
das der hammer das sieht sehr sehr schön
fix ja was machst du ich mache hier
gerade den teich ein wenig schöner dann
sind jetzt noch eine andere weise
produktiv und zwar machen wir das ganze
so ein bisschen anschaulicher
so kümmert da mal wir machen habe ich
mir überlegt mit dem schiff mit ich hab
grad schon wieder geguckt
ich würde jetzt einfach sagen dass mit
dem ding mit dem zauber tisch dann
müssen wir halt noch auf das zucker um
bisschen warten aber wir brauchen nun
warte mal ganz kurz ich hab noch so und
so viel zeit ich habe übrigens auch noch
erde und kann die da oben auch mal ganz
kurz hinsetzen
ich habe eine kleine idee du kannst hier
so ein bisschen terraforming betreibe
ich mal hier nun ja dahin was in so ein
paar sachen hat wollte ich denn jetzt
machen ich hatte so ein zug aber lass
ich mal stehen damit dass weiter wächst
nahm ja so ich mal ganz kurz hier nach
unten
was wolltest du sagen ja ich überleg mal
gerade ging halt mal so ein bisschen
ratlos moment wie macht man sich nochmal
zauber tisch hubertus minecraft
ausgeglichen für obsidian zwei diamanten
und dann wenn auch obsidian ja ganz viel
ganz ganz viel ich musste mal ganze
disconnect das ruckeln also mithin ganz
viel hast ja auch schon abgebaut
ja ist in der truhe okay wenn man schon
sieben diamanten kraft komme ja und
zuschauer die
bum bum bum bum bum bum
rumba von lima der zauber tisch hin
wir müssen wir eventuell aber die müssen
wir diesmal verbessern mit bücherregalen
damit wir direkt eine gute verzauberung
drauf wenn wir spieler machen dann durch
das zuckerrohr na ja ich setze aber erst
mal da hin wenn es richtig schön
gestaltetes ja hier unten muss ich echt
sagen ja hier oben finde ich irgendwie
sieht schon schön aus wie die kleine
kätzchen
natürlich muss jetzt mal ein parcours
laufen muss ich hier über bin ich hier
drauf dann mache ich so gehe ich wenn
ich im katzen pflege von grünergy gar
kein bier möchtest du dich mal wieder
ein paar neue hasborn nicht so viele
eier das können vielleicht mal wieder
machen weil wieder aus tradition einfach
mal sieben eier mit ja da unten keine
stadt diesen blöden cobblestone und
diesen ganzen anderen leben retten was
rotes umsetzen was ich nun hier wird den
gehegen läuft bei dir ich persönlich vom
mal ein huhn kam raus schade
ich werde jetzt noch mal alle partien
mit weizen mit den samen müsste man noch
mal wachsen erleben das dauert halt
durch den lechte geht das hat aber recht
schnell
das haben wir herausgefunden jahr hat
euch wieder startklar bis sicher ja
eigentlich sehr sicher was hast du
gemacht oder gar nichts hier war mal was
wo ist das circa wohin ich als ich
gerade was noch da hast du in die wasser
weg gebaut legal zu macht ihr habt 0
gemacht
er ist das immer ein stück ja wir hatten
hier vor den vier stücken ihr habe ich
doch zu büchern gemacht hab doch gesagt
1 dass ich stehen damit dass noch
wachsen kann
alle mit ewigkeiten ich dachte das wäre
alles auch wenn wir es ist ja praktisch
alles weg dass die ewigkeit wenn wir
wieder kommen haben wir zwei mickrige
zuckerrohr von crafter ein bisschen als
coo und wächst schon wieder wegen ihrer
penne lala damit sie ihren strom was das
bringt
wofür wird brauchen wir wollen wir das
guck mal hier kommt auch wieder gleich
zuckerrohr dabei entweder viel später
aber erst die 42 skifans so aber ist
viel schöner alles aus
ja ich würde es auch gerade und man noch
ein bisschen schöner aber an diese leere
karten schaut einfach mal drauf es
bringt sie denn jetzt
so können wir gucken wurde truhe ist von
oben eventuelle auf dem berg oder so
oder vielleicht auch meine hand nehmen
ja gerne so dies jetzt aufgebaut die
karte ganz einfach mal drauf gucken ja
cool krass solchen wieder nach unten
momentchen was soll ich denn machen ich
das mal hier die strahlen dass wir das
noch mal mit einer karte ja das bringt
uns dieser jahre drei goldnuggets habe
ich noch
na ja schön ist sie auf jeden fall
hast du noch mehr gold oder smaragdgrün
wenn wir echt langeweile haben kann man
einfach mal auf gold als partner holen
von unten ja und dieses diese andere
monumente werden lassen runter dann ja
meine folge ist aber auch jetzt jeden
moment eigentlich wollte es noch ganz
kurz diese familie oder das ist ja nur
ein holz der angebracht habe ich
vollidioten er war schon wieder schön
ausloten
ja das mit dem hengst dahin muss noch
ein bisschen vollendet werden
genau da gut an sortiere ich mich jetzt
eben noch schnell und dann wenn wir
wieder komm ich freuen
ich glaube wir sind beide schon bin ich
süchtig je nachdem wie schnell die ganze
zeit ist ohne die karte
kürbiskerne die können wir auch noch
jemand an pflanzen packe ich auch mal
hier ein bisschen sub mama noch da so
eine kiste die können wir noch irgendwo
hinstellen
obwohl kisten haben eigentlich erst mal
echt genug diesen brauch ich mal eben ab
jetzt immer irgendwie sieht gut aus
neben dem kessel haben wir gar nicht
ihre gute frage hier eine ecke
vielleicht nie ist mein stück vom kuchen
wenn du hunger hast dann ist ja wirklich
klassisch problem keiner 8 ich wollte
hier noch eben die roten steine hinbauen
und danach machen weil man ende für die
folge weil damit das ja noch ein
bisschen schöner aus ich bin ja auch so
gespannt was man findet hier dieses
monument mit block auf diamond bekommt
da muss doch dass diese scheiße was neue
können wir doch eigentlich auch mal
abbauen oder komplett dichtmachen hobby
ja damit er nichts durch ok warte ich
brauche schon glück zu
zwar fehlen noch ein paar blöcke hast
noch genug ja wohl froh dass jetzt viel
geiler hieraus viel viel geiler mio
franken hinweist dass noch hässlich dann
müsste man normalerweise auch mal dicht
machen
wer die leute hinter die leiter müssen
auch noch die roten blöcke ein paar
sachen halt dazu nicht machen möchte ich
einfach so wer genau einfach mal dicht
machen vielleicht auch mit einer anderen
lok farbe orange ja machte mit orange
packe meine blöcke da wieder rein
dann würde ich sagen freunde auf dem
vorstand noch ja ich packte ihn einfach
meine kiste man eben auch mal öffnet ihr
die mittellosen kreis ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr der folge eine positive
bewertung geben würdet weil wir zwar
nicht so viel geschafft haben aber wir
haben doch das ganze wunderschön
gestaltet dass ich viel viel schöner
hier aus mittlerweile eben was machst du
jetzt hier
da kommen auch so einer hin und hier
kommt wir rot hin ganz entspannen so er
weiß nicht 9 kieslich das ist so gar
nicht mal so und es ist nicht schön das
ist nicht mal so gleichmäßig das ist nur
zwei breit ja eben deswegen halte ich
dachte mir doch so das i-tüpfelchen so
die schärfe bei der ganzen sache machen
derzeit als trainer hast recht da machen
wir da ist wenn ihr wollt und schreibt
uns das bitte in die kommentare falls
ihr einen live stream haben wollt wo wir
so ein paar sachen design
dann schreibt uns dass damit wir das
ganze ein bisschen schöner gestalten
sonst will ich sagen wir werden uns
morgen in der folge komme wieder in
alter frische und an zweiter reihe und
schmidt